ready for some lunch  is that really what we're having Brody  have I ever steered you wrong I'm going  to show you how we make a frozen pizza a  little less I've got some steamed  broccoli here and some little baby  Tomatoes I've got some leftover  rotisserie chicken here some olives  a little bit of nooch nutritional yeast  extra cheese because why not and some  toasted pine nuts  then we just throw it in the oven  [Music]  and Brody this is the magic a little  spicy honey come on wow that really does  look like  all right Brody listen up we've got lots  of fiber in all of our added veg plus  some added protein in our nooch and our  chicken healthy fats in our olives and  our pine nuts and some hot honey to  bring it up a notch you're not gonna cut  me a piece oh yeah here you go